when we as the class began talking about
this people are comfortable talking
about their home life their religion
their intimate relations their
boyfriends or girlfriends but very
uncomfortable of talking about money
mm-hmm and I often wonder how we can
overcome that barrier because i think if
we got people to come to Owen the
position and the opportunities that
those positions give them then we could
actually begin to engage more fully in
creating change yeah i think that i also
think though that that perhaps because
there's so much information available to
people today that that's going to be
less and less of an issue so the thing
is you can google me and find my net
worth somewhere out there and and i know
that and so the thing is is it makes it
I've less incentive to run away from
that because people are going to find it
out anyway right you know so why not why
not then take control of what you're
doing with that information so directing
people towards okay no it's not just
that look here's you know a young rich
girl but these are some interesting
issues that that money is addressing and
so you can actually use that to call
attention to issue areas that you're
passionate about